here are three surefire ways to become a  charismatic person today we'll be  studying tom cruise a man who is always  smooth and who has never displayed a  moment of weird behavior step one touch  things the more things you touch the  more dominant you appear see how he  touched that desk he owns that desk now  that's hit that's his [ __ ] step two  sit like you're trying to take a [ __ ]  ancient astronomers date this pose back  to the late 1940s it is the time-tested  alpha male pose signifying you're ready  to dominate your enemy's territory step  3 be really cool see how he's smiling  like that that is cool and i want him to  be my dad in the next video we'll be  analyzing a hollywood actress who  everyone on reddit hates this week for  some reason